g
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis là parce que je suis contre les
violences policières des deux ça fait
des années que je me bats comble et j'ai
soutenu le dow matin horaire 20 la
famille d'adama traoré dès le début
avant qu'il y ait tant de monde et
aujourd'hui je crois que les violences
policières ont des paroles ont dépassé
vraiment la limite de ce qu'on peut
comprendre et analyser
hier j'étais pour la bondi pour le jeune
gabriel qui s'est fait dépenser le
visage et par la police il faut là qu'on
se pose la question fils qui est
responsable
ces rassemblements complet suite à tous
les événements qui a eu la semaine
dernière celle qui arrive juste avant
c'est la mort deux heures sous la halle
c'est un homme noir notre frère des
scènes qui vont en tout cas se calquer
sur la mort de mon petit frère ils ont
su bien à damas après trois gendarmes
sur mac os x 10 3
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]